Here, the possible solutions for p are between negative 2 3rds and positive 1
3rd. Now, that's amazing problem solving if you got this one correct. To start
this problem, we want to subtract 2 from both sides of the inequality. This
gives us a quadratic expression on the left and zero on the right. Now, we
want to find the 0s or the values of p that make this quadratic expression
equal to 0. We find factors of negative 18 that summed to positive 3. Those two
factors are positive 6 and negative 3, and we use them to rewrite the middle
term of plus 3p. Using factoring by grouping, we get the factors 3p plus 2 and
3p minus 1. Next, we set each factor equal to zero, and then we solve for the
values of p, so p could equal negative 2 3rds or p could equal positive 1 3rd.
Next, we use our two zero ro values to create three different intervals. And
now, it's just a matter of testing each one to see which ones are part of the
solution. For the first interval, we'll plug in p is equal to negative 1. When
we plug in this value for p, we'll get this statement, 4 is less than 0. We
know this statement is not true, so we exclude this interval from our solution
set. For the second interval, we'll test the value of zero. We know zeros in
between these two fractions, since one of them is negative and the other one is
positive. When we plug in p equals 0, we get the statement negative 2 is less
than 0. This is definitely true, so this part is part of our solution set. For
the third interval, we'll test p equals 1 and we'll get the statement 10 is
less than 0. We know this is false, so this is not part of our solution, which
leaves us with this interval only. Any value between negative 2 3rds and
positive 1 3rd will make our original inequality true. We also use parentheses
here and in our interval notation since this is just a less than than symbol.
We can't be equal to zero.